good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight joe biden delivered this
country's first ever state of ukraine
address last night biden spoke for a
little more than an hour before a joint
session of congress he talked far more
about ukraine and with much greater
passion than about any other topic
if that sounds strange for an american
president in a speech that's supposed to
be about america it didn't seem weird at
all within the context of last night
biden delivered exactly the speech his
audience wanted to hear virtually every
lawmaker in the room last night from
both parties arrived wearing some
version of the ukrainian flag house
minority leader kevin mccarthy came with
both a ukrainian themed pocket square
and a ukrainian flag lapel pin that's
about as ukrainian as you can get
even the president of ukraine doesn't do
that very often
what mccarthy conspicuously didn't do
was don an american flag pin
no not at all and many others went
without that too because within the
context of last night the american flag
was literally irrelevant
lots of our leaders feel that way all of
a sudden
at this stage the full force of
america's federal government the white
house the congress the many intelligence
and defense and law enforcement agencies
all of it has been redirected to avenge
the invasion of ukraine
notice the verb avenge not defend
now ideally you'd like to think there'd
be some way to defend ukraine from
russian aggression that might be worth
doing
but at this point there isn't it's too
late joe biden's deterrent strategy
failed putin already invaded the country
short of destroying ukraine there is no
way to liberate ukraine by force
all we can do is punish the russians for
what they've already done and that joe
biden told us last night is exactly what
he plans to do watch
the ruble has already lost 30 percent of
his value the russian stock market has
lost 40 percent of its value
and trading remains suspended
the russian economy is reeling
and putin alone is the one to blame
so the russian economy is being
destroyed is destroyed imagine living in
a country where the currency drops 30
points in a single day what would that
feel like well 143 million russians now
know they're much poorer than they were
two days ago
only a relative handful of those
russians had any role in the invasion of
ukraine many of them opposed it but all
of them are being hurt as their economy
comes apart and that's fine because they
all deserve it
michael mcfaul barack obama's former
ambassador to moscow who now teaches at
stanford university announced today that
every single person in russia every
single one bears the guilt of the
ukraine invasion quote there are no more
innocent neutral russians anymore
everyone has to make a choice support or
oppose this war
so to restate and be clear there's no
such thing as an innocent russian one of
our foremost russia scholars has told us
so putin may have given the orders to
invade ukraine but six-year-old girls in
saint petersburg should pay the price
for it because they deserve it
their eight-year-old grandmothers
deserve it too
in order to fight tyranny the united
states must embrace collective
punishment hurt the children to bring
justice these are our values because
vladimir putin is a moral monster
now these are not traditional western
concepts of justice but joe biden
wholeheartedly endorses them and so does
a dominant bipartisan coalition in the
united states congress
the question is is this a wise course
now we can't say
far be it for us to suggest thinking
through world-changing policies in any
way before enacting them
pausing to reflect we have learned is
disloyal adult moral calculations are
treason thinking about your own country
is a crime
act now or be denounced so we're going
to withhold judgment on all of this
but we did notice one question that joe
biden failed to answer last end or even
address and that is
what's the point of all of this
putin is bad no one in america is going
to argue with that but will destroying
the entire russian economy make putin
less bad
will it force russian troops to withdraw
from ukraine and if it will how exactly
will that work and how long will it take
or is the plan bigger than that is the
idea that we can force vladimir putin
from office entirely okay will that work
and if it does work what happens to
russia after vladimir putin leaves would
the next russian president be an
improvement over putin or would russia
descend into barbarous chaos like iraq
syria and afghanistan did once we
overthrew their governments
now you may not care what happens to
russia but you have to wonder what would
become of russia's enormous nuclear
stockpile under those circumstances take
a moment and think
are there potentially ways that
thousands of unsecured russian nukes
might pose a long-term threat to the
united states
something to think about not that anyone
is
the immediate goal again the bipartisan
goal is to turn russia into a pariah
state
now again the question isn't whether
vladimir putin deserves that
it's more than a moral question
the question is how will that work out
for us and for the world american
citizens have a right to ask that
question
start with history how has that worked
with iran and north korea now that those
countries are cut off from the
fraternity of civilized nations are they
more or less predictable
are they more or less dangerous to the
united states
could it be possible that some of these
steps in the end turn out to be
counterproductive to our interests
that's something to consider
keep in mind the people the very people
proposing all of this are the very same
people who defunded our police
departments and destroyed our schools
and tore down the teddy roosevelt statue
in new york city they're the ones who
armed the taliban they're the ones who
devalued the us dollar they're the ones
who brought human slavery back to libya
they're very good at wrecking things
it's what they do they planned the iraq
war and they never apologized for it
so we might want to make sure they don't
wreck anything else ever again
especially this country
but once again joe biden didn't address
any of that last night he was too deep
in his world war ii fantasies with
himself playing fdr
for all of his moral outrage against
russia well deserved though it may be
biden made no mention of china's role in
the invasion of ukraine and that's weird
more than any other country on earth
china made this invasion possible
china is russia's most important ally in
this war against ukraine
so you've got to ask yourself as long as
everyone's culpable who was involved
why aren't we tanking china's currency
why aren't we banning chinese planes
from american airspace why aren't we
confiscating the yachts of chinese
oligarchs
but biden never told us
maybe someone will ask him
but with that fide was off to other
topics but not the topics you would
expect but i'd never mentioned the word
equity a single time last night we
checked the transcript
that's very strange equity was supposed
to be the central focus of his entire
administration that was just 13 months
ago he told us that and we still have
the tape
we need to open the promise of america
to every american
and that means we need to make the issue
of racial equity not just an issue for
any one department of government
it has to be the business of the whole
of government
well that is a very abrupt change and
again it's worth marking these changes
because no one seems to notice them
in the space of one year equity went
from quote the business of the whole
government to something the president
doesn't even mention in a state of the
union address what's that about
was equity not quite as popular as they
expected
and there were a number of moments like
that in last night's speech moments that
left you scratching your head at one
point joe biden said we needed to fund
police departments the ones that his
party defunded and then in case you
hadn't had enough beers by that point
joe biden said we must
secure the border
now why is joe biden saying this far be
it for us to suggest there were
terrifying internal polls suggesting he
has to say those things
but we're starting to conclude that
because just a few minutes after joe
biden said we need to secure the border
he announced amnesty for millions of
foreign nationals who snuck into our
country we also have that tape watch
provide a pathway to citizens for
dreamers
those with temporary status farm workers
essential workers
revise our laws
so businesses have workers they need
and families don't wait decades to
reunite
it's not only the right thing to do it's
economically smart thing to do
yeah it's the economically smart thing
to do give your job to a foreigner and
if you don't you're immoral so that
category just to restate is dreamers
those with temporary status farm workers
and something called essential workers
who do you think who's come across the
border illegally the millions in the
last 13 months would be denied the
classification essential workers of
course they're all essential every
single one of them
so moments after telling us he's going
to secure the border joe biden just
announced that everyone who's already
snuck across the border gets to become a
u.s citizen and needless to say a
democratic voter like immediately
because it's the right thing to do
that was the portion of the speech where
he talked about our country so the first
part was about how borders are
sacrosanct and we should go to war to
protect other people's borders and the
second part was everyone who's already
snuck in gets to become an american
citizen does that apply to russian
soldiers in ukraine what are the
principles here exactly
then biden went on to mention someone
called kentaji brown jackson now that's
not a name most americans know because
kentucky brown jackson has been an
appellate judge for less than a year
but joe biden assured us she is quote
one of our top legal minds watch we all
know one of the most serious
constitutional responsibility a
president has
is nominating someone to serve
on the united states supreme court
as i did four days ago
i've nominated the circuit court of
appeals
katangi brown jackson
one of our nation's top legal minds
so is contangi brown jackson a name that
even joe biden has trouble pronouncing
one of the top legal minds in the entire
country certainly hope so biden's right
appointing her is one of his gravest
constitutional duties
so it might be time for joe biden to let
us know what kantaji brown jackson's
lsat score was what how does she do in
the lsat
why wouldn't he tell us that that would
settle the question conclusively as to
whether she's a once in a generation
legal talent the next learned at hand
it would seem like americans in a
democracy have a right to know that and
much more before giving her a lifetime
appointment but we didn't hear that
and that was just one of many things
that joe biden left unsaid last night he
alluded for example to rising crime but
not his role in it
he claimed instead that it's gun
companies not prosecutors funded by
george soros not the celebrity funds
that bail out murderers
that have made this country more
dangerous watch
band assault weapons of high capacity
magazines hold up a hundred rounds
you think the deer are wearing kevlar
vests
look repeal the liability shield that
makes gun manufacturers the only
industry in america that can't be sued
the only one
now far be it for us to fact check joe
biden like questioning his foreign
policy that's russian disinformation
it's disloyal it may be punishable under
our treason laws
but we should point out that what you
just heard is what's the word a lie gun
manufacturers of course can be sued it
happens all the time but now that joe
biden mentioned it there is in fact an
industry in america that has total legal
immunity from lawsuits that immunity was
granted to that industry by congress
in fact
here you have a president who
single-handedly turned that industry's
corporate executives into billionaire
oligarchs by forcing americans to use
their products they had to but here's
the best part if the americans who were
forced to use those products were killed
or injured by those products as many
thousands have been over the last year
they have no legal recourse they can't
sue the industry they can't even
complain about it on television or
mention it on social media and now there
can actual experts physicians and nurses
for example they've been silenced
you know this perfectly well
biden knew this he was flacking for
these companies the minute he got to the
podium just like he flacked for the
credit card companies in delaware many
of the people he was speaking to last
night in the room are invested in that
industry
but he never said a word about it
that's a hud hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else